à la question du figaro l'état en
fait-il assez pour les entreprises
vous êtes partagé 52 % répondent oui 48%
répondre non dans les commentaires aussi
vous êtes partagés
si certains se félicitent en disant
merci quand les petites entreprises
merci pour les commerces chez d'autres
c'est le doute qui domine doutes sur
l'efficacité de cette aide doute sur la
réalité de cette aide alors l'état
fait-il le maximum l'état en fait-il
assez pour les entreprises ça méritait
qu'on vous pose la question dont vous
croyez pas en tout cas ça mérite un
débat à mon avis
[Musique]
si vous appréciez ce débat si vous
appréciez cette controverse merci de
nous le dire par un pouce levé sur
youtube et surtout de partager cette
vidéo vous allez retrouver agnès
verdier-molinié directrice générale de
l'institut français de recherche sur
l'administration publique
l'ifrap à l'opposé vous allez y trouver
hervé nathan direct ancien directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne est
aujourd'hui chroniqueur à alternatives
économiques
vous allez entendre également la vie le
regard l'expérience de renaud dutreil
ancien ministre des pme de jacques
chirac est également entrepreneur et
enfin en juge de paix marc landré
rédacteur en chef au figaro économie
alors l'état en fait ils assez pour les
entreprises
là c'est hervé nathan qui attaque bille
en tête
c'est paradoxal j'en ai envie de dire
qu'il en fait pas assez
à l'opposé les autres interlocuteurs ne
sont pas d'accord du tout d'accord lors
de mon point de vue la réponse apportée
par l'état et par le prison d'ain
république donc emmanuel macron à la cri
du grenat virus est exceptionnel par son
ampleur par son efficacité et par sa
rapidité
aujourd'hui l'état fait le maximum de ce
qu'il peut faire
on peut dire que l'état a déclenché un
plan qui est massive
l'état fait beaucoup aussi pour garantir
des emprunts permettre des emprunts par
les entreprises à l'arrière on compte
déjà plusieurs milliards d'emprunts en
question car on veut dire ce qui fait
des choses la crise étant supérieure à
celle de 2008 à son avis n'a pas attendu
pour mettre en place un certain nombre
de mesures
il ya les faire évoluer dans le temps
l'état a mis en place un dispositif qui
est assez large pour pallier des baisses
d'activité et les problèmes de
trésorerie au mois de mars
le courage ce dispositif au mois d'avril
il a tout à fait il a dit de manière
totalement explicite que de toute façon
si jamais il y avait besoin de continuer
dans le temps d'aller au delà des
mesures
il fallait en premier sur le mois de mai
par exemple ne pas répondre présent
c'est le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
le président de la république si les
arguments de ceux qui disent que l'êta
en fait sinon assez du moins beaucoup
sont assez convaincante reste une
objection elle aussi très convaincante
celles formulées par hervé nathan
elle porte sur les masques on peut dire
ce qu'on veut sur l'image que tu fais
pas tout à fait aussi utile que pensent
les gens
mais à partir moment où les gens pensent
que pour aller au travail la protection
c'est d'avoir quelque chose sur lui
n'est pour pouvoir travailler en
sécurité il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que de trouver des masques si on veut
les envoyer au travail et l'état est
incapable de fournir ces masques il a
sacrifié le milliard et demi de masques
qu'ils avaient en stock en 2005 jusqu'en
2000 jusqu'en 2013 et d'un sacrifice qui
a été fait par les gouvernements
précédents
et depuis l'état traîne ce goulet
l'autre objections porte sur une mesure
nouvelle en tous les cas inédite par son
ampleur le recours au chômage ou plus
exactement à l'activité partielle il ya
huit milliards et demi d'euros qui ont
pu visiter sur deux mois par le
gouvernement ou le gouvernement a dit
que si jamais il fallait aller plus loin
notamment roger ça on a tombé bas on
irait donc on voit bien que c'est la
principale mesure qui a été mise en
oeuvre est allée des mises en oeuvre
avec beaucoup de succès en france
les salariés eux ils perdent 20 % de
leur rémunération
quand ils sont au chômage partiel donc
un vrai sacrifice qui est demandé aux
salariés comme si son ex partiel la
vraie question l'autre question tous les
cas celle qui monte dans vos
commentaires
c'est celle qui porte sur les dividendes
versés aux actionnaires des entreprises
aidées par l'état
on devrait interdire les dividendes se
traîne logique je pense que le il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui aimerait bien
que les tapas une décision radicale là
dessus pourquoi parce que ça leur
éviterait les directions d'entreprise
leur éviterait d'avoir à expliquer à
leurs actionnaires
maintenant remettre en cause de façon
durable la distribution de dividendes
c'est absurde puisque les dividendes
rémunère des investissements réalisés
par des apporteurs de capitaux et les
entreprises elles ont besoin de ces
capitaux s'il ya plus de dividendes
il y aura plus de capitaux et il aura
plus de capitaux pour développer les
entreprises françaises pour les sociétés
qui ont l'état au capital
l'étape décidé que les dividendes ne
seront pas versés pour les entreprises
qui n'ont pas demandé d'être de l'état
il est évident qu'il faut pas les
empêcher de verser les dividendes
ensuite des dividendes ça permet aussi
parfois à des associations à des
fondations de fonctionner à des
personnes d'avoir pour qui ont pour seul
revenu parfois ou qui ont des petits
revenus de retraite mais qui ont des
revenus aussi d'actions il faut pas non
plus tout déstabilisé
sous prétexte de cette crise reste une
toute dernière question posée par
guillaume roquette dans son édito du
figaro magazine
mais où va-t-on trouver l'argent c'est
mon grand souci c'est comment
allons-nous gérer ce surcroît de dette
que les états à juste titre aujourd'hui
sont en train de contracter pour sauver
la mise de l'économie mondiale mais qui
resteront des fardeaux dont il faudra
bien assumer le poids ou trouver des
solution de délestage dans les années
qui viennent un malheureusement en 2008
qu'est ce qu'on a fait derrière on a
fait un matraquage fiscal massif sur les
ménages et sur les entreprises ça nous a
pas permis de bénéficier de la reprise
comme les autres pays et on est resté
englué dans la crise économique jusqu'à
la prise de conscience le cic eux le
pack de responsabilité il faut pas
refaire les mêmes erreurs baisser ou
monter les impôts c'était déjà le
dilemme en 2008
c'est un beau sujet de polémique a beau
sujet de débat et là j'attends votre
avis
[Musique]
non